here's the televised mental institution
MSNBC with racist Joy Reed and she
actually aired a clip of drag queen
Story Hour and I don't think this
segment went exactly how she intended or
just to go on because I don't think most
people have ever seen one I've been to
one with kids there with like kids there
I want to show you guys what drag queen
story hours look like because there was
a drag show at that was supposed to be
at this club uh when this attack
happened I just want those who don't
know what they look like to see what one
looks like this is cut two please play
this
the hair so a lot of drag queens have
really big big big hair so the hair on
the drag queen goes up up up so you can
put your hands on your head like this
and go up up up
so the hair on the drag queen goes up up
up up up up up up up up up up up up the
hair on the drag queen goes up up up
all through the town good job
and you know it it makes me sad Brandon
that that scares right wing people so
much that they would try to ban it or
your Governor sued people over it and
then people act surprised when there's
violence against people who are trans
and lgbtq okay little throwaway first
Joy Reid years ago on her blog used to
go after Charlie Crist all the time
because he was a closeted gay Republican
so she deleted all those posts and then
pretended that somebody hacked into her
blog but she has a history of Anthony
gayness herself now I want to be clear
about one thing here there's a
difference between drag queens and trans
people what you saw there was a dude
dressed up as a chick I have no evidence
I was told by Joy Reid that that's a
drag queen not a trans person so that is
a guy who identifies as a guy who
dresses up like a chicken for some
reason wants to read children's stories
to children and why would you want a
five-year-old to have to look at that
thing and think about what is going on
here what what why would you want to
enter into look as an adult you can live
your life any way you you see fit and
it's ultimately up to a parent obviously
to decide what they want to see and what
they want their child to see and what
they wanted them to be affected by and
all of those things but there's obvious
like it's just so obvious it's
ridiculous so that but I just want to
make the point that there is a
difference between a drag queen and a
trans person who fundamentally feels
that they are in the wrong body and then
often goes through the the surgeries to
transition into the other gender this
would be someone like Kailyn Caitlyn
Jenner right Bruce Jenner who became
Caitlyn Jenner uh Bruce did the whole
thing Bruce chopped Bruno Bruce added
the boobs chopped the Wang Bruce is
living as a woman I I'll it's okay good
to go okay Caitlyn it's all good but
that does not mean you have to infect
the minds of children with this stuff
and I would recommend that you read
irreversible damage by Abigail schreier
who I've had on the show how it is
becoming a social contagion that
suddenly trans the amount of kids who
identify as trans is exploding usually
it's young girls who want to transition
to boys and then they realize a year or
two later after sometimes they've taken
these puberty blockers and all sorts of
other stuff that oh no it was just a
little bit of a phase or it was a social
contagion remember the movie Heathers it
was a social contagion that everyone
starts acting the exact same way
but there is a bizarre
movement in mainstream media to
normalize drag queens with kids again
why don't drag queens okay so they do
events at gay nightclubs okay that's
fine
and then why don't they do events with
anyone else other than kids again the
actuaries the accountants the dentists
the shoe salesmen whoever it might be
why doesn't the NBA bring in a bunch of
drag queens to do team building with the
Knicks
bizarre right it has to be with kids